welcome back to the y it's been a while
i haven't done it in forever it seems it
could be fun for good old times say
leave your memes on the red at 19 year
olds now measure your peeps
[Music]
mp in eu parliament has a pewdiepie
chair and they're still not world peace
i don't get it that's amazing by the way
i think i've seen her before
so good
oh yeah she she forgot to charge it you
got to put the leds on that bad boy
can you imagine all the world leaders
sitting around in a circle with
pewdiepie chairs listen they're all just
surprised wait you
you bought one too yeah it's 3.99
obviously what other chair would i
possibly buy and you know yay
[Music]
such a dead meme i don't know what
before we continue quick word from
sponsor i thought i told you about the
link
i thought i told you about the surprise
gift
well i guess i will have to do it again
listen here are the facts if you browse
online other people can steal all your
information all your passwords
everything
the whole kaput okay
fact solution nor vpn is that simple
they got a strict no logs policy and it
helps you keep surfing the web safely
everyone should have it i haven't
you you don't have one oh you don't you
haven't used the link oh god
fact you can't watch certain shows
online because of stupid country
restrictions or access certain websites
because of other dumb restrictions that
public networks put i don't know nordvpn
solution so take control of your
internet experience today use the link
in description that's the way you sign
up that's nordvpn.com pewdiepie and by
doing so every purchase of a two-year
plan will get you by using the link
description one month for free you're
welcome it's a fair trade it's a fair
trade take it you got five seconds
all right you're a tough deal i throw in
surprise gift
that's it final offer link in
description okay all right
how about this thing
if you
just want to try it you're not sold on
it just try it bro just try it use the
link and try it and if you don't like it
money back 30 day money back guarantee
that's it that's it i'm done i cannot
that's it stay safe protect your data
and watch it download whatever you want
baby nordvpn.com pewdiepie use the link
let's go on with the video i spent a
hundred hours adding peers into
minecraft
let's go
oh this is for that was from my uh
vlog in malaysia
no bali i went to bali
hell yeah that is
not bali
yeah get in there
i've killed all kinds of
pokemon
dogs but if there's one thing i never
hunted
that's a creeper full video on my
channel leaving comments
who are we pewds roasting kid for
wearing slipper on wrong foot meanwhile
jack wearing his headphones backwards oh
my god how could he even hear them
i understand that this is just a joke
it's just for fun okay but i
hate these comments
stop it remember when i snapped at that
one kid for telling me my nintendo
switch was wrong i think i think it's
like i get it it's it's hilarious he's
wearing them wrong what a doofus but
it's like i want to read comments about
the [ __ ] video not that jack wore his
headphones wrong by six thousand people
like it's is that really the most
interesting part uh let's take a moment
in my opinions yes this is more like it
this is what i want just say how good i
am that's what i want to read in all the
comments
none of this is what i did wrong all
what i did right look at them games
and that's my uh that's my left arm on
the left so
you know even better gains plus i am
kind of i am kind of flexing i might
make uh
a workout video again uh update
maybe i do really appreciate you guys
notice it's not like uh i don't know
it's motivating i appreciate it
considering how much uh you guys like to
clown on me
i've gotten so sensitive over the years
i'm like can you
one of your nice things guys
stop roasting me please
me playing animal crossing in the other
room my husband playing elder ring yeah
that's
that's pretty accurate i would say
marzip still plays it too speaking of
jack he just sent me hilarious elder
ring memes
there it is i never thought i'd die
fighting side by side with an elf how
about side by side with yourself i could
do that
yeah i like this
yeah
[Music]
oh
sorry don't
look damn who's that uh who's that girl
on the twitch i got a sub does she have
an only fence baby please stop listening
to that song you can't even speak
swedish hell yeah this song slacks
[Music]
national anthem these are all big
peepees by the way uh solid stuff guys
i'm sorry for ignoring you okay i'm
sorry uh from now on for every boob i
see i will look at 20 books to
compensate
how many is i mean i saw half a boob
a nip slip i had to read
i was gonna do another book review and
then i was like you know what it's
easier to just record the y
i'm sorry
here's dissing printers uh printing who
gives a [ __ ] anyway the guy who hacked
printers worldwide to get pewds more
subs rest in peace he died as soon as i
said that actually finally met the king
of youtube herself in toronto
this is such a good shot that i honestly
live in such a weird timeline like i
never thought i would collide worse with
elon musk so i kind of like is this real
no that's definitely not real
but g feels so good though hey elon i
know you're a billionaire or whatever if
you want to be a double billionaire
i suggest you invest
we don't need
i don't know what i'm talking about just
enter code pewdiepie and you could win
you could win holy we were at the cinema
yesterday and watching batman and
literally the commercials said
i think it was for oreos or something
they were like submit and you could win
and we were like me and jack we're just
looking at each other like when what
what do you mean you could you could win
guys uh if you subscribe to the channel
when you realize 2018 was four years ago
bruh the last two years uh yeah
boom but you know what that means we
just can check out quicker so it's good
uh what's going on with the iranian
iranian bros
nordvpn.com pewdiepie that's all i'm
gonna say i support bros from all across
the nation i transcend all politics if
everyone just bought the damn pewdiepie
chair world peace would be existing i
keep telling you but no one listens in
the czech girl understood it wait this
is an old pose it is yeah
marketa gregorova okay based
god damn it
wouldn't it be cool though if you could
plant an egg that would be sick someone
has tried it you know someone's tried it
you know how people figure out all these
cool stuff it's not because people are
smart it's because people just tried all
these dumb first so let's stop
pretending everyone's so good and smart
and let's stop pretending like you
wouldn't plan an egg uh smash or pass
all 898 pokemon jesus christ jack didn't
smash her press every snap animatronic
me waiting for pewter's take uh well the
obvious one would be then all
minecraft animals here we go uh villager
that's a smash for sure uh axolotl
that's a pass they're gross maybe the
pink one bad is a pass although the face
i never seen the face it does look kind
of nice cat is surpassed
i'm not gonna say well
no it's a pass
obviously
pass
obviously pass i'm married hello
smash
let's go
i made the website crash i act what the
[ __ ] i loaded so many things at once
whoops
sorry dick minecraft if you want full
version smash like on video i'll go
through everything strongest man in
sweden versus weakest men in greece
that was really fun uh he he replied to
the video too i'm so happy yeah
yeah
no match the cables i don't want to see
that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
this is where i hate me okay it's a very
big baby
waiting for my dogs yay
my gay dogs well
[ __ ] look at this message time for
two handing
bro let's go
i love the try butthole one and it's
always cracking up it's very good i
speak english now i saw you being born
and i saw that the way friday
oh yeah it's friday's pretty quite now
that's right
so i rolled interest
[Music]
people are fetishizing the sadness of me
uh quitting which it might be a perfect
time for me to finally announce
uh parents eat your food it's not that
hot the food yes
i look way too good in those god damn
imagine if i was twitch girl oh mama my
husband is strong muscular sweet marcy's
husband
[Music]
[Applause]
play with neighbors kid neighbor's kid
and his games
apparently my dad thought that video was
funny so i was very happy about that
uh pewdiepie jeans i made two years ago
that was great
ah one of my favorite movies i read
through a scene named houseman castle
but his feelings and might say i love it
big peepee huge peepee
i don't even i don't even know where
that's from i need to watch more anime
man or maybe not that looks kind of
weird coming from me that's rich hell
yeah this is god-like setup you know why
because
no wires cable management 10 out of 10.
love it
that's all that matters
never seen someone so happy because of a
helmet give me that
look
let's go i gotta help me
[Laughter]
guys i've been kind of swept up with uh
playing elder ring the past month but so
i haven't really had time to work on
videos as much
but uh i had really fun trying to do
when i came back you know kind of
different type of videos with edgar and
stuff like that i want to do more of
that and it seems like you guys really
enjoy it too so i'm really happy about
that just been really actually genuinely
really appreciating all the positive
feedback and support lately it does
really motivate me so thank you for that
and uh i'll see you in the next video
until then bro fish